a pleasure to have you here
today you just come from the president
of the turkish republic
we are interested to hear your
impressions the floor is yours mr
president
for president merci beaucoup
good afternoon everyone today
we had strange distinctions with
president erdogan
on the future of eu turkey relations
at our european council meeting last
month
we discussed the situation in the
eastern mediterranean
and the eu's relationship with turkey
the eu's strategic interest remains
a stable and secure environment in the
eastern mediterranean
and a mutually beneficial and positive
relationship
with turkey we welcome
the continuation of the bilateral
exploitability tools
between greece and turkey and we welcome
the forthcoming visit
of the greek foreign minister to turkey
on cyprus
the eu remains committed to the relaunch
of the settlement tools as an active
observer the eu fully supports
the u.n let process and we look forward
to the informal meeting
that will be held in a few weeks time
in recent months we have witnessed
a de-escalation this is a positive
development
which must be sustained and enhanced
we have told president erdogan that the
eu
is ready to put a concrete
and positive agenda on the table based
on three pillars economic cooperation
migration and people-to-people contacts
and mobility
our engagement will be progressive
proportional
and reversible and we hope
turkey will cease this window of
opportunity
how do we see it concretely
the eu is by far the largest trading
partner of turkey
economic cooperation will be envisaged
in a number of areas
the european council has invited the
commission to start
preparatory work we will also consider
high-level dialogues on issues of mutual
concern
such as regional issues public health
climate
or counter-terrorism and we will explore
ways to strengthen cooperation on
people-to-people contact
and mobility on migration
we appreciate turkish hosting of 4
million syrian refugees
and agree that eu assistance be
continued
the commission will soon present a
proposal for the financing
for syrian refugees in turkey jordan
and lebanon
[Music]
the rule of law and respect of
fundamental rights
are core values of the european union
and we shared with president erdogan our
deep worries
on the latest developments in turkey in
this respect
in particular on the freedom of speech
and the targeting of political parties
and media
the promotion of women's rights and
turkeys withdrawal from the
istanbul convention have raised serious
concerns in europe
this morning we had and i had a very
interesting meeting
on these topics with representatives
from the united nations
and you and women dialogue on these
issues remains an essential part
of our eu turkey relationship
we also discussed regional and foreign
policy issues
differences remain but new opportunities
for peace and stability
emerged especially in libya which i
visited last sunday
we have one crucial message on this
all foreign fighters and troops must
leave
the libyan territory the european union
has a strategic interest in developing a
cooperative
and mutually beneficial relationship
with turkey and at the same time we are
determined
to defend eu and member state interests
and to promote our values
we extend our hand with our progressive
agenda
and its opportunity to see this
opportunity
in a solid and sustainable manner
for its part the eu is ready to walk the
talk
and we will assess the progress at our
european council meeting in june
thank you
indeed um turkey shows
um interest in re-engaging with the
european union
in a constructive way and we've come to
turkey
to give our relationship a new momentum
and in this respect
we had an interesting first meeting with
president
erdogan and indeed we discussed four
areas in depth in which the european
union and turkey would have both benefit
from enhanced cooperation the first area
is the one where we want to strengthen
our economic ties the european union is
turkey's number one
import and export partner and european
companies
are a crucial source of investment and
turkey
within the customs union is an important
partner in many crucial value chains we
have
to stimulate trade further we will
address
the current difficulties we have without
any doubts
in the implementation of our customs
union
and we will work to modernize
our customs unions framework this
customs union
is a unique framework we have with no
other country
and therefore we are in addition looking
into innovative
ways not only to modernize the customs
union
but also to boost public and private
cooperation
with a focus on the green and the
digital transitions
the second area of enhanced cooperation
are the high-level dialogues
topic number one should be in a
high-level dialogue
the fight against climate change this is
a common concern and we all sense
by now um the danger that is
that we are facing with increasing
climate change
and um the uh follow-up
consequences in our countries
therefore this should be one of the
major topics in a high-level dialogue
the second one is for sure public health
we have been discussing the coverage
situation we've been discussing
the vaccination progress the variance
and of course topics
like the green digital certificate and
other ones connected
to the covet situation the third topic
we've been discussing is that the
european commission will
explore ways to strengthen cooperation
on people-to-people contacts
and mobility the participation of turkey
in the european union programs such as
for example
erasmus plus a horizon europe
has proven very valuable in the past
and this is a corporation we would be
interested
in expanding it to the coming years
i believe this is of benefit for the two
of us
and the fourth area of cooperation is
concerning
refugees and migration
the eu turkey statement of 2016
remains valid and has brought positive
results
this is mainly with regard to the syrian
refugees and the host communities
in turkey but it is also true for
combating human trafficking and
smuggling
and therefore we expect turkey
to stand by its commitment and to
deliver on them this includes preventing
irregular departure
and it also includes resuming return
operations from the greek islands
to turkey without any delay
this is for us a crucial commitment and
it would be a major
show of goodwill that this
migration cooperation does work on our
side
we will continue to support refugees and
host
communities by this we're supporting
turkey
that is hosting four million refugees
and living up to its shell to this
challenge
basic humanitarian needs education
and health care will remain priorities
but eu funding should in the future
increasingly
power better opportunities for refugees
to earn their own livelihood
i'm very much committed to ensuring the
continuity
of european funding in this area
and our support is clearly a sign of
europe's solidarity to turkey
and an investment in shared stability
and this is not only concerning turkey
but this is also
true as well as for other important host
countries for example
lebanon or jordan i will travel to amman
later this afternoon to discuss these
topics with the jordan king the
commission will soon make a proposal
that reflects
these principles last but
certainly not least we're aiming
for an honest partnership and that means
that a partnership
between the eu and turkey enables us to
strengthen
what brings us closer but also to be
very frank and to address what divides
us
and today shall michelle and i clearly
underlined
that respect for fundamental rights
and the rule of law are crucial for the
european union
this must be an integral part of our
relationship
turkey must respect international human
rights
rules and standards to which by the way
the country has committed itself
as a founding member of the council of
europe
i am deeply worried about the fact that
turkey withdrew from the istanbul
convention
this is about protecting women and
protecting
children against violence and this is
clearly the wrong signal
right now the european union will never
hesitate
to point out further negative
developments
and this is also true for unilateral
actions
against eu member states like greece or
cyprus
in some we want to move forward towards
much better relations in future
but we are at the beginning of this road
and the weeks and months ahead will
show how far we can go on this road
together
thank you
thank you miss and mr president and we
are going to take
three questions if you are loved each
sort of jazz
from the reuters news agency uh i had a
question about the timetable of the
planned steps that you mentioned just
now uh it seems that ankara wants these
steps to be implemented rather
quickly whereas the eu is proposing this
as more of a process that might take
some time
during your meeting with president
erdogan today did you have a chance to
discuss a concrete timeline for these
steps
and secondly what impression did you get
from president erdogan about remaining
true to the commitments that turkey has
made in terms of de-escalation
thank you very much this was in my
opinion an important uh
meeting an important moment because
because it was the opportunity for us to
to explain
what's the european vision and what's a
possible positive agenda
based on what we think should be the
priorities in the
in the future but there is one certainty
uh
i intend to put again this point at the
agenda on the gender of the open council
in june
uh it means that now the commission
will work very actively and probably
also in partnership
with the turkish authorities in order to
prepare
to prepare the next steps
yes indeed so
this is the beginning of a process we're
at the beginning of a road together
and uh where this road leads us to is
also not only very much depending of
course of the content of negotiations
we have together but also dependent on
a clear commitment to from turkey
to maintain this positive momentum
so the sustainability
of what we've seen over the last weeks
has to be proven
and indeed in that context
it is for us important that there is a
true
true attitude towards respecting human
rights respecting the rule of law
and moving in that direction we had an
intensive discussion
indeed about the withdrawal from the
istanbul convention
because we think this is not the right
signal at the moment being
it is not the right signal anyhow
because the istanbul convention is very
clear in protecting women and
children in a broad scoped scope
and in a encompassing
context so this is a topic
where we will never get tired to
be very clear on it this is hampering
the process
and we wish for a different approach
from german press agency hello
so you already mentioned uh
human rights and you said that you had a
discussion about the istanbul convention
with mr erdogan
i'm wondering if you also had a chance
to discuss
issues like the attempt to shut down
turkish largest opposition party http
cases under terror charges against
german citizens
or the fact that turkey ignores decision
decisions of the european court of human
rights for example to release osman
kavala and celetine demitas
did you have a discussion about these
cases and what did mr erdogan say about
that
and then connected to this i want to
know
nevertheless the european union wants to
deepen trade ties with turkey and
human rights organizations and also the
german opposition
is very concerned about this approach
and would you say that turkey's behavior
and the mediterranean and the migration
deal
have priority over human rights issues
for the european union
and if you don't agree what do you think
what leads you to the conclusion that
warnings
without pressure will be heard from mr
erdogan
thank you very much human rights issues
are non-negotiable so they have
an absolute priority without any
question
we were very clear on that that this is
our position and indeed we have been
for example discussing the fact that the
european court
of human rights was clear and is clear
on kabbalah and democracy
and that
as a founding member of the european
council
it is important that turkey respects
rulings of the european court
of human rights and indeed in the
istanbul convention we certainly
did not convince but we urge turkey to
reverse
its decision because it is the first
international binding instrument to
combat violence against women and
children
and it's today indeed more important
than ever to support it
so we need allies in the global
fight against violence against women and
children
okay thank you and if you already take
more than three questions thank you the
press conference is over
thank you miss and mr president
if you could please stay at your seats
so that the principals can leave without
having a crowd
and have the cameras go to the side so
that we can move out
easily and without crowds
you